so we were showing our fourth season now
that I think back on that to think that
we had the audacity to think like oh
we're ready to show they're in New York
Fashion Week after four seasons I don't
know if it's because I'm the oldest
child or it's because I'm Dyslexic for
whatever reason I just always listened
to my gut let's strap ourselves to this
rocket ship and see what happens
my heart was pounding and I knew what
was at stake and I knew that we've
leveraged our future on this show maybe
10 minutes before the show I got a phone
call that Kanye West was on the way that
was like God you know called
let's have to come check you out hey
what people will talk about this stuff
that may be emotional and that you could
be afraid of but the other side of it is
if you do this and you have a hit
luckily behalf of Awesome business
partners who are also lifelong friends
they were there when I was driving my
grandmother's car you know driving
around doing production myself we've
been friends since the fifth grade
we talked probably 50 times a day she
would knock on my door every single day
but no appointment that really told me
something that
absolutely there's supreme confidence
and belief in each one of us when you
have that you have a team that really
feels empowered to you know take risks
and run their element of the business
like it's their own running through
Vietnam was the second show it was so
challenging because it was all about
creating washed textures so right before
the show we got the blue soy back and it
was purple and literally every person
was like well this is just what we're
gonna have to show and that was like no
there's no way three nights in a row
till 6 o'clock the Morning Sun was
coming up recutting that whole story and
the blue story came in and it was
perfect
went back to the apartment and I just
like danced around my collection by
myself that was like I love this the
growth after that collection was insane
we signed on with Bergdorf Goodman
picked up Barney Sachs mr. Porter the
traffic to the website went up probably
our best day to date was the day we
released denim within maybe seven to ten
minutes most of the popular sizes were
gone
this is like my second bed it all runs
through me like our design team is
myself Nobu and Kumi it's three people
and we're pumping out full collections
with footwear and accessories can we to
ply the rim just so it holds this
right so I think what we have to do is
you'll come up with crazy ideas you know
and our job is to make that happen
other than that incredible we can adjust
the tree we custom-make fabrics it's not
easy it's not it goes cost-efficient way
to do it but we do it because we believe
that really makes difference I could cry
talking about no but that's my god
that's like my brother I watch him
spinning yarns you know and what that
will do to a texture of a French terry
it was probably this challenging piece
it was one that it was one of the most
challenging pieces of the entire
collection guys after the Vietnam show I
want to try and come back down to earth
a little bit we started this company
with 30,000 bucks so long nights with no
food and no hope no guarantee that this
is gonna work and that can put you in a
dark place out of fear I really want to
try and tell like an eerie story with
this collection we typically start with
texture we drew inspiration from a
Japanese stitching technique called
slushy go stitching it's all
hand-stitched people think that this is
a print but it's actually a knit and
then it's completely waterproof this is
what we call cake mock it's a wool
French terry when you wash it the wool
actually seeps through and creates this
eerie almost fog look I wanted to try to
tap back into that fear and really try
new techniques new silhouettes I wanted
to push myself over that line
I never thought that this was gonna
happen I never thought that it would
ever get this big yeah but life really
hasn't changed that much honestly I
don't really want to let headlines or
what people think give in to my head
because then you start doing it for that